you're like where is it murder mystery
I'm gonna assume was about like the army
the morning toast okay I'll kill you who
did it it was muddy ax in the studio
with a candlestick guys we're so excited
what a weekend what a weekend there's oh
my gosh you unpacked we have decided to
dedicate like 75% of this episode to the
Royal Wedding the top five stories are
all Royal Wedding funded oh the sound is
nice art no sound for the whole time
yeah I'm pretty sure okay let's start
again cuz apparently there was no sound
all you missed we said good morning
everyone we didn't to Millennials you
mommy give it a no world I said good
morning from the number one listened to
two podcasts in New Jersey and
Massachusetts you also said that you had
Doritos in your taxes yes well I was
gonna leave that out for the second time
oh no and we also said that Dear John is
being turned into a Bravo scripted TV
show and then we wondered what Dear John
is about we assumed it's a murder
mystery because every podcast is a
murder mystery except for the morning
toast then we suggested we should turn
the morning Co soon to a murder mystery
where Claudia kills me in the studio
with a candlestick which sounds painful
that's really all you missed you guys
and they're so glad we repeated it and
then I'm so then we announced then we
announced at 75% of this show
approximately it's gonna be about the
royal wedding because we are shaped to
the core are you not trip to the core I
don't know are we solving sound issues
yeah we are you gonna just wait sure I
feel like a teacher okay there's a
buzzing there's a buzzing check it's
called dirty John not tear Shawn I feel
like a teacher
I'll wait okay I think we're good you're
gonna okay so I should make shout out to
New Jersey and Massachusetts that are
clearly in tune with what's necessary as
opposed to the other 48 seat so that's
the thing like when you're when you're
evaluating podcasts it's always
important to keep in mind what it's
necessary and it's obvious that being
you know a well rounded informed
millennial is really important to the
people of Massachusetts in New Jersey so
I've never really wanted to with
Massachusetts but now I kind of wanna go
I think like
it's my hair doing weird curly things in
the front like it's not doing what's not
in okay so here's the thing I was
obviously live Instagram storying like
the entire time and I did catch a bunch
of flack for like making fun of Megan
and stress because like you really and
you know what I kind of agree you're
really not supposed to say not nice
things about people on their wedding day
that's like the one day year where
they're like exempt from that I mean
however like her wedding was made for
our consumption and what were just
supposed to praise everything about it
like if that's the point then why do we
didn't show up to work today right and
we're here to like I'm of so many
different minds on this because when I
woke up I miss my alarm for seven
o'clock I woke up at nine I turned on
the TV I saw all the celebrities leaving
and I was like what a great time to turn
this on but then I saw the first few
pictures that came out and justice for
Megan Marvel because the first few
pictures that came out were horrible
she's like strangled in her bail like
not good her dress needs an ironing and
tailoring and then throughout the rest
of the day some really beautiful shots
came out but like the first impression
is the lasting impression and my first
impression was not good
here's the thing and there was so much
hype and build-up and it's like all this
build-up and very underwhelming it's
like the build-up never got to explode
you know she's gonna see what people are
saying people are saying come to
Massachusetts we sound great yeah we
sound wonderful I definitely want to
come to Massachusetts we should do a
show in Boston for the boss teens yeah I
think that's what they call themselves
it's like you the boss teens yes
actually I heard the boss teens are late
as [ __ ] they clearly are cuz we're the
number one pack has Massachusetts yeah
but give it up with about students give
it up for the best students you guys
okay now give it up for Megan mark oh
what a day what a weekend know what the
[ __ ] weekend let's okay
so we're gonna cover the whole thing
from from front to back but I see as
just like as a consumer of the royal
wedding from start to finish
I give this overall extravaganza like an
eight and a half just so I'm like an
entertainer
and you're giving Kate and William a ten
yeah okay a thurman entertainment
perspective
oh it was highly entertaining all the
American celebrities that wormed their
way in like so enter so there's one of
our stories because I'm just confused as
to like how and why Sir yeah exactly
like
Williams love her I feel like she was
like invited she would've been invited
even on both sides
yes exactly because she had an amazing
seat she was literally sitting there
cheating
two rows behind whoria like first row
like Oprah like had an okay see Oprah
had an okay seat and like Oprah didn't
get a plus-one sadness has been right
there no more when we saw Stedman and we
didn't know I said I know that guy's
famous so Jackie's like no it's not but
not what I said yes he did it's not what
I said the conversation differently
however mine do after they suggested who
you thought it would be who you thought
it was and I was like no it's not no I
knew it I was like oh yes he's famous
but it's I was close it's not who you
say whatever whatever okay I want to
talk about her dresses someone said her
dress was apparently $500,000 first
dress was a hundred thousand and then I
don't know how much her second dress was
but it's not like she even paid for it
it's okay
do you think that the that the British
people are okay with the fact that like
that's why their tax dollars are going
five hundred thousand dollar dress their
tax dollars went there because I think
it was free like we're all talking about
Yvonne Chi and we're all talking about
Stella McCartney oh for sure
the creative director of Yvonne she is a
woman the first ever fence so a
McCartney fashion house but like a
French house has like its first woman
creative director and so Megan Marco was
paying tribute to that which is so nice
but here's the thing about the dress
underwhelming AF and then it goes back
to the fact that she needs a tailor it's
the same problem we've had this entire
time and now I there have been a few
things that people have been saying as
to why her dress was unfitted one people
are saying and this kind of bothers me
that like maybe it was loose because she
might be pregnant which is like not what
a woman can't what has to wear a tight
dress or else she's pregnant like that's
so reductive no I also don't think I
think there's limitations around how
tight your dress can be when you're a
royal when you know the chance was mad
tight I know it I don't need it to be
kind I just wanted to be fitted I think
that maybe in the last few days like it
was just a lot earlier that she lost
weight but that's not even an excuse
because like you should have a tailor on
staff and like if I were a guest at her
wedding which I would clearly never be
because of all the things that I've said
about her yeah I would have gotten her a
tailor as my gift yet like the scenes
just to follow her around yeah because
like she she needs she needs tailoring
left
and even her second dress which was
perfect perfection it still was at the
waist so here's my theory on it I think
she was inspired by girl with no jobs
wedding dress because they looked really
similar he did sorry
so neck a boatneck ed but mine was way
prettier yeah it's like yes people are
like perfect I know people were like
it's so simple and understated it's
beautiful I totally agree but like
simple and understated it's not the vibe
you're going for at a royal wedding like
and she's a pretty important one like
she's marrying an important one not
she's marrying Diana's son not marrying
like some ranch is married like even
though William is going to be king he is
with Stila Prince when you got married
Harry is equally prince like there it's
important to you know it's not as
important as William Kate but it's still
up here it's just everybody using the
argument that like she was simple and
understated during her wedding day like
no makeup like I think that's a nice
gesture for like a regular person not
for a wedding being paid being paid for
by the the people of London someone said
that there were family paid for the
wedding out of their own pocket and that
we shouldn't make that distinction I
don't really think it I don't know the
truth it all comes out of it's all like
the same pop like we pay for the salary
that the Queen doesn't have has a credit
card no she has a handbag though what's
in it
gum sure yeah chapstick she looked mad
cute and I was like you know like the
green accent I want to talk for a second
about Meghan Marcos mom and I want to I
want to talk about Meghan Merkel's
makeup while we're here because like she
like she was not wearing a lot of makeup
which she's beautiful her skin is all
she doesn't need makeup and I agree with
everyone that said that but when you're
getting married in front of the world's
cameras and there are pictures of you
from every single angle from far and
near up close it was like the up-close
pictures were beautiful because she's
beautiful but far away like you need a
little bit of cop like you need a little
lipstick no no this is the thing I love
you don't need to wear makeup you don't
need to do anything but like don't you
want to look a little different on your
wedding day she looked like she was in
suits like she looks prettier in her
suits wedding than she did in this
wedding she wore less makeup on her
wedding day than she did on her
engagement announcement like it's it's a
nice like idea like you don't have to
wear me you don't like women you don't
need to wear makeup to be beautiful
because you don't but like you do need
the definition to pop when your take
being pictures or taking a view from
miles away yeah no no and like I mean
I'm not trying to be negative I swear
I'm not it's just like the more I look
at the pictures the more beautiful she
is
there's no she's it's under diamonds
she's stunning she's like so pretty and
like of course like we're just jealous
that she did like anyway was not wearing
makeup to her own wedding but like I
don't know I just I expected more that's
it and it's like as much as this is her
wedding day like it's really not a it's
off for her like it's for the people and
has the people we deserve like more you
know if we're waking up at [ __ ] 5:00
a.m. like gave us the works but then she
turned to change into that Stella
McCartney halter dress and gave us the
word and gave us three pictures and we
didn't even get to like so I think more
pictures will be released from the party
you think I know but like they
definitely have pictures and they
definitely portraits in that dress that
dress was stunning and her getting into
that car like that was a glamour I was
waiting for blue princess honoring just
everything the glitz the glam the car
how are you looking like [ __ ] James
Bond and you know it's so funny as I saw
those pictures and I was like holy [ __ ]
then I saw the video of them actually
doing the pictures like it was a little
quiet and like awkward I was like oh
this is weird like it's just like you
expect there to be like crowds cheering
it's dead silent and like the video is
just like really awkward I did she's and
like that makes sense because if you're
gonna be a princess like you need to be
able to like do your own face like throw
it on quickly
Megan not to her own no she did not do
her own so someone else was responsible
for I heard that they spent 18 grand I'm
hearing me go I heard that - how is that
possible her hair didn't stay in place
and then for the evening she did do
intentional pieces okay that down which
were naive nning was so glad like I was
so here for it maybe she heard our cries
maybe I don't know I just like I liked
the idea of the dress even if it was
fitted I just don't think it's like such
a beautiful like wowza kind of dress but
I really need to talk about Megan
Merkel's mom go for it I think she is
like an unsung hero and like I kind of
like was just like thinking about her
the whole time like she was completely
alone like literally the only person she
knew there was her daughter like she was
kind of busy like I don't know I just
felt like it was probably scary like be
like alone in such a situation that's so
damn familiar what your use
I'm like there's just been so much like
negative press around your family like I
don't know I thought she carried herself
with like a lot of grace and I was
really impressed by her and like I think
Megan like you know people like just
like they're like a reflection of their
moms like I get that vibe from her and
her mom must be so proud like I'm sorry
when you marry a prince you become a
princess I totally gala tease I don't
want to hear about any of this when you
marry a prince but the fact that Queen
Elizabeth's husband is not a king like
literally no sense that makes a little
bit of sense because like he would then
he would be the king like no I know it
makes no [ __ ] sense what's even
crazier is that like I he like had to
stop his feet in throw tantrums to even
be a prince like he was just a Duke for
so long and then he was like I need some
respect around here and she made him a
prince an old man yes an old man who's a
prince
check it an old man who's a prince makes
no sense like Harry and William like our
princess like they're like eligible
bachelors but like just 94 year old man
being a prince it's like he - I think
it'd be better if he was a Duke what
about Charles
also a prince I don't think he's gonna
be the king um and also they just wanted
to take a moment to say that Camilla's
hat was so bad let's talk about okay
let's go through where we are we done
uh-oh I wanted to echo I agree with what
you said about Megan Markos mom
completely and it's just like she made
up for the whole family
yeah no and she looked great she like
looked like she came through like we
know her dress is very berry yeah and
she wore the same like shade of green as
a queen like it was all working not the
same shade like the same green but no
complimenting no one's comparing the two
no no it was good I really I like the
mohawk do you know anything about why
everyone has to wear a hat like for
other than like no that's just it's like
a part of their culture it's not the
silliness it's like literally a part of
their tradition where yeah it's like
I've never seen anyone in the American
wearing a wedding wear what Harry were
it's just a part of their history and
all these people are important yeah we
should have gotten hats for today uh
actually thought about it but like
they're expensive are they yeah I'm
sorry guys we're on a tight budget okay
so there were a few moments that
everyone shook the [ __ ] up about okay
when
I saw Megan with like you look amazing
no okay you guys I'm betting something
controversial Harry is more in love with
Megan than Megan isn't Harry he was
crying she was acting no she was like
she's so like I can't explain it like
mature like she's above all of this like
she's not fazed by any of this like
she's keeping it all to herself and like
he like is like obsessed with her like I
think that I think that like he loves
her more than she loves him I agree but
I think also her acting skills really
paid off and kicked in because like the
Queen shows no expression ever and like
as well you're not supposed to and again
it's like permanent smize yeah the whole
time like she nailed the role no no well
when she first showed up in that dress I
was like yeah when she sure first showed
up in that dress I was like damn that is
like a hallmark budget if I've ever seen
one you know like she looks like she was
playing you in that movie Mary Harry or
like the movie she was literally in like
she just looks like she got like the
Wardrobe from that but then she brought
okay I know it's me I don't want to say
anything bad about her outfit anymore
sighs okay there were a few okay and
also the carriage ride really that was
the moment for me did you watch this was
made her to be because you only saw like
yes both yeah like you didn't see the
tragedy the tragedy at the bottom you
just such a like a beautiful decolletage
I love that word she's just so thin and
like her [ __ ] shoulders are like
perfect perpendicular like squares her
her chin no that is what most is most
impressive her neck
a sad nothing hurt like skin is
permanently attached to her bone like I
were to go get kind of like I would show
her but so even the picture that was
released of them kissing like you have
to read the body language like she's
like pulling back like he's so much more
in love like I'm telling you I think
he's just they're both I think they both
love each other but he's like so excited
it doesn't know how to like keep it
together like this is just so exciting
right he's like talking off the cuff the
whole time like he doesn't care that
there are cameras that are reading his
lady's always been a rough he's so aware
which i think is nice to actually take
it really serious and respect it yeah
because it's [ __ ] serious yeah I
really want to talk about the
celebrities that were there cuz I need
to understand like the connection okay
let's talk first about Amal Clooney and
George well obviously they were there
because they're so annoying and they get
invited to everything
um she I think she was one of my favor
best-dressed guests you know what I was
underwhelmed by her really I thought it
was very plain and simple and I was I
was thinking I was like this is what
people wear to a wedding but I guess
everyone changed because it was like
Church where no that's what it's
supposed to be I didn't realize that
either that's not like that would talk
if you had to go like where you're like
cap sleeve
yeah thanks dress mouth is like the most
gorgeous woman in the world she doesn't
have a stitch of fat on her so she's
gonna look great in anything I just
thought it was like a little Plain Jane
you know but like I don't know I just I
loved everything about it and I feel
like she knows it's like it's not about
her well let's go see some police-style
because we don't have the pictures okay
so why do you think they were invited
because like the UN and Milan Megan I
don't seem so far off like that made
sense I they definitely met and I feel
like the Queen and the royal family were
like that's a good look for us like
let's bring them yeah I agree
let's bring them into the it makes it
more like cosmopolitan yes they're very
well we're very choosy about the
American side too they were less choosy
about the British liberties like James
Blunt was there he was okay who else
Oprah obviously oh my god she is epic
and I was watching her during the
ceremony and she was living for it like
she like she is the ideal wedding guest
she looked so [ __ ] cute and just like
I would want to open up my wedding I
feel she feels the love she's a good
participant she claps she laughs she
cries you know like she gets involved
totally wonder if she spoke at evening
but like she can she would have been an
amazing orator but so I'm just curious
like do you think she was a guest of
Megan I think she would have been
invited
even if Megan wasn't American why I
think because she's definitely met the
Queen and she's only in the good graces
of the Royals but I think Miss yet
willing Cates
I don't know probably okay Serena
Williams and Alexis Ohanian
okay I don't really get the connection
but like I was just happy to see her and
like her husband is can read it read it
okay that's so crazy
no I know I'm so rich people do things
richer her
I don't think it's so rich she's so rich
but like reddit is crazy but she's like
the highest-paid athlete in the world
look it up another time you know what I
think we've had this conversation no we
hadn't had Salo an a-rod oh yeah just
like Jenna ranks boyfriend
the hockey player Carrie Underwood's
husband joke about that Stoli joke oh my
god and then I was watching Sex and the
City and he's in it he looks like an a
waiter who like shows this tattoo to
Carrie
yes and they think Jeremiah was above
he's a waiter named Jeremiah but also an
artist don't you fire Oh someone says
Serena Williams is friends with Meghan
oh cool they're great is that good
friends like she's definitely very
selective about who she's friends with
but she only picks like the cream of the
crop
but see here's the thing it's like yeah
now everyone wants to be a friend
because she's a princess but like before
that she was like a low-level Cable
actor like why do people want to be your
friend but how did she manage to make
such good friends no I think okay this
is when she was a low-level Cable actor
like that's where her friendship with
like crankin Chopra was formed and like
a few other like notable stills and then
junka Chopra here Megan Marco without
Harry like me here
quantico here yes suits here no Quantico
got canceled yeah but like it wasn't it
ended up you guys it's so crazy that
this show suits like which would have
just been like another you know show on
USA said I wasn't sure whenever it will
now go down in history without suits she
wouldn't be princess and also something
else that's confusing because the way
that Harry and Megan met like I heard a
lot of different stories friends with
the mother friends did them up but then
I also was watching like some you know
document a documentary I don't even know
what to call it where they're just like
hyping them up some high footage yeah
where they said they met in the club
maybe like a friend in the club but all
this at them and then I also read
somewhere that they like went to a group
dinner on there they met at the dinner
well that is a friendly potato - yeah so
has type of place in London maybe it was
so because I cares Morgan love when I
came late Piers Morgan wasn't invited
yeah oh my god true he wrote the nicest
piece about because he's in love with
her he like he's a big fan of suits and
they used to DM and then when she was in
London they went to drinks and like he
was in love with her and she was just
being like Marco sparkle no and then
that night
she went to meet friends and that's
where she met Harry so Piers Morgan says
I don't know cuz he's in love with her
so he's he's like he's biased yeah no
we're getting half a story from Pierce
Morgan because he's just blinded by love
but oh my god and Piers Morgan had the
sister on who like he's talking trash
about Megan and he she ripped into her
out of control that girls he ripped into
I didn't watch it but she's out cut
troll Pippin James Middleton Arizona
obviously yes she looks like I was on I
see her husband's like hot yeah they're
cute they seem they seem I just read it
Oh cute it was just kind of what a great
dress for a pregnancy a burgeoning belly
well James and Sophia Blount James Bond
yeah beautiful that's wild the hell was
he doing there the beckham's obviously
Beckham's obviously he just Alba and his
fiance Sabrina oh he's hot
yeah that was like a great face to see
now kitty Spencer who's Princess Diana's
nice which I think but also qualifier
hair is Prince Harry's cousin cousin
yeah who was the best-dressed woman at
the Royal Wedding I agree she looks like
Kate Upton first of all oh my God look
at this face and this is like just a
candid photograph yeah no she got into
google what she wore she were like an
emerald everyone agrees that she was and
she was very in theme with like the
green vibe that the Royals were going
for and apparently I also read that
Harry and Megan donated all their
wedding flowers to hospice like places
oh that's own taxes that's so nice when
people do that i theorize or hospitals
hospices
multiple hospice multiple hospices or a
hospice Hospice is one hospices how do
you know that though it could be like
moose loose it's loose it's loose
there were five loose okay I trust mr.
kitty sensor because she was the
best-dressed woman there
now the suit stars who really won the
lottery
stepped in [ __ ] who you know who statue
and bellisari Belisario is married to
Patrick Adams who's in suits and trained
Belisario from Pretty Little Liars on
ABC Family now that the wedding was at
the Royal Wedding I follow her on
Instagram so I was like keeping up with
her the whole week she handled the whole
thing with grace she was like obviously
very excited to be there but like wasn't
being like a weenie American tourist she
was being very respectful I don't love
though she wore that like let's not
ochre cutout let's not talk about
people's outfits okay
but you know the choker cutout thing
that's like a very 2017 and will be
dated in a year so good on you
Steven Victoria Beckham obviously
Georgia no miles Sarah Rafferty I do not
know who she is Sarah Ferguson was
invited the Duchess of York well they
raised her because she's divorced but
didn't really have a leg to stand on
anymore but she wasn't disgraced because
she was divorced she was disgraced cuz
like that met her feet like were some
something we're seems like a weird like
you know what's the most automated thing
about Sarah Ferguson she's in an episode
of Friends you know it's also under a
it's like she's Fergie Jackie did you
hear that she's in an episode of Friends
what was she doing she plays herself she
wouldn't be the first actor went to
London real family they went to London
and he like Joey like ran into her and
they to make sure that's so crazy
yeah I'm actually not sure if it was the
real one or an actress portraying her
but I think it was the real one James
Corden and his wife were there perfect
fence
her apparently she made a really funny
speech at the reception it's just like
how do all these people know each other
like when you think okay when you think
of like what at your wedding like the
people you love the most and of knowing
along it's like make speeches James
Corden like he doesn't even know them
you know what do you mean no but I think
it's like okay we have a comedian in the
Rhino and he MC dealings like let's if I
happen to invite like a rogue MC and
then like my called for one I feel like
hey like do you want to do it apparently
he was really funny and made all the
jokes have people where you need to hear
it also SNL first I'm gonna give another
perhaps as now because they paranoia
wedding within 12 hours of when it
happened they copied although every like
this to me that's impressive which was
really impressive they did like a sketch
where Harry is like introducing the
wedding party it was decent but then
they had Kenan on Weekend Update being
the Reverend really really funny that
Brendan was crazy
so he was your Z and he was on for so
long yeah no boy was that clan her feet
were hurting her for sure oh my god yeah
justice for her feet I was thinking like
she's probably well at a certain point
yeah they do that a lot that's more
painful but they had like pillows yeah
like this like a dog bed and like she's
becoming a princess halation you do
it's the price you pay yeah who else
Oh Tom Hardy was there with the bald
head and he's hot Charlotte Ridley
Chelsea Davy Harry's ex girl who I liked
really was holding out hope for right
but then I was watching in another hight
video for the royal couple where they go
through their history so she dated
Chelsea and then he dated this woman
Christina Krishna who is Cortana she is
like literally like if you live in
London like you want to be her or her
friend no totally because the definition
of a socialite and there were all these
like photos of her where she was just
like in a crop top like the worst
possible photos and she looks flawless
and every single one but then she really
didn't want to be a princess she like
couldn't take it and Krista does like
such a cool name yeah she didn't want to
be a princess imagine painted that cool
and then the commentator for the height
video was like who in their right mind
would want to be a princess apparently
like it's really treacherous of course
you have literally no privacy you have
to be here like your life is not your
own literally like you can't go anywhere
without like fleets of security like I'm
sure it's fun for like a week but like
long run
Danika into it I don't think I could
actually no it's a lot of being on your
feet and like saying hi to people small
talk and like hugs and she can
definitely not I don't think it's and
bending down to talk to small children
yeah no I would more so like go for the
role of like Queen Elizabeth like in her
90s already cuz like they can't they
don't expect her like she cares a lot
nobody else she does shake hands she and
she goes on like a tour of the
Commonwealth so epic no she's so epic I
love her so much she's so like petite
and it's like so sad one of the
commentators was saying that this is her
last wedding will say well you never
know with modern medicine like no like
if the next wedding nowadays is George
no okay so like those girls Beatrice and
Eugenia uh-huh if they get married does
the Queen go for sure yeah because she's
there if they get married well Hugh
Jeannie's engaged so she will be getting
married soon but if they get married is
that on TV
I don't think subtle things no but I
think the Queen still goes right no but
this is her last like real royal I don't
think she really cares she loves a
wedding and like so many went it but
then people are saying like it's you
guys we should all embrace this because
it's our last royal wedding for a really
long time until George but like we've
also never had a carnation
which we will be having true you know
why are you so like fatalist it's a
happy occasion it's a wedding also like
I'm down for the Queen to be queen
forever because like the longer she's
Queen the shorter that Prince Charles is
quick King who does nothing for me
no I really need willing Kate to like
rule the world there Gigi it's like the
picture of class two perfectly spoken
about whether or not they're gonna skip
over Charles we have like we both think
that they are but we that's a I also
read that it's impossible oh okay so but
then the Queen can do whatever she wants
like do you watch Royals he literally is
a crazy man yeah and that's really like
a very real show snitch just watched all
four seasons I'm about to start starting
to see like today
okay dynasty's on Netflix you guys
that'll be our Riverdale 2018 yes to it
and then next fall we could do after
Steve dynasty's cool guys they're
hosting dynasty's hosts will do
dynasties with the bastian okay okay
Gabriel mocked oh my god from see he is
so hot he's Jewish
I love him there was a Jew at your
element
yeah Kate Middleton's half Jewish and I
also read my second quarter Joshy yeah
you know it's like if someone
great-great-great-great grandmother like
had sex with the Jew once they're like
she's for tuition we take them they're
ours I keep my mouth oh my God he's so
hot and you know how I know I'm from he
is the love interest in because I said
so which is literally my favorite movie
and I just love Gabriel mocked and like
he's so like unfazed by all this Fame
you know and he really did a good job at
the Royal Wedding however justice for
the students actors because they were
not invited to the reception because
there were 600 people at the church
ceremony and only 200 were invited to
the reception and the suits actors were
not that's so shady because like the the
the church one is like the public one
where like the pictures are so like they
say faces like yeah we were here but
like that they don't mean anything turn
Priyanka Chopra when yeah Serena
Williams when yeah okay but so it's like
she was only invited her cool form would
you rather get like it's like the
reception is the cool the place to be
like that's where you're going down that
you don't get their picture taken no one
like would care or know that you were
there so which would be bad well I don't
probably the church the pictures look
forever memories fade totally even
though apparently her what this
reception was like everything was go
into the details in a little bit but it
was like someone source was quoted like
it was the kind of experience and like
fun times that money can't pay for you
know you know those kind of kinds of
evenings I Joe yes you do yeah
apparently there was a there was a lunch
afterwards everyone yeah everyone got a
free lunch even though there's no such
thing Sir Elton John was there obviously
with his with his rose gold frames he's
so cute Cowell Middleton looking Gorger
and just like the perfect like mother of
the sister-in-law you know oh yeah like
you know like it's so not about her you
know she looked about her looks she to
make about her until this morning me too
and then there was a Priyanka Chopra and
her girl gang I don't know who these
women are but I think that they are
actresses and they like walked in
looking like Sex in the City
oh really and they all looked great
Priyanka wasn't loving one of those
ladies is this Canadian woman who's two
kids were the Train holders and she's
very yeah Mulroney's she's like this
very glamorous stylist from Canada she
does the prime minister's wife like
she's really cool I heard Meagan are
like best friends okay and Megan is
their godmother Oh cute so it's like
weird that is like this is where so
Megan's like this small town like weenie
she's really a nobody but she really has
these like deep connection she was very
hairy like with very cool people it's so
odd so I think like suits was like hoppy
like it's almost like Riverdale where
it's like not like it's not not a
network but if you watch you're a big
fan of the show and like we think of
Camilla and Lilly like in the highest
regard you know he but not like so many
other Oprah other people mind and then
also she does a lot of humanitarian work
before she was Mary and I think that
like you know opened up her rolodex it's
so weird that her name is Rachel right
and like but I feel like Rachel's more
of a princess names I totally because
it's baby spoke about this we did yeah
well we I think me more so said that
Megan like
isn't no we said she should really go by
Rachel but that's like that's she's
really change her name in the middle of
your life just cause like talk show yeah
very popular one in New Jersey and
Massachusetts but they said that you
should I don't know
and then Zara and Mike Tindall who are
like related to the royal family and I
maybe she had something to do with Zara
I don't know it's all too much for me
like I was just overwhelmed by emotion
and you know what's so funny it's like I
didn't even watch it like I kept up on
social media a lot and like watch all
the clips like I never turned on my
actual TV and just so crazy how I know
everything about it I'm totally immersed
but I never even watched I agree well it
took me like honestly 48 hours to get
totally immersed in but I feel oh no and
then I did watch I watched on Saturday
and I they kept replaying it over and
over again I'm thinking every bar that I
went to in Florida was playing Division
through a wedding I just made whole day
was well what's so funny is Jackie and I
were saying I'm like a lot of people
less the amount of people who tuned in
to Harry and Meghan's was significantly
less than William II kids but it's like
because you don't even need to watch it
like to know and to know about it yeah
and like Cosmo clipped out everything I
needed to see but more Americans watched
this one then William and Kate which
makes sense America so 18 million people
watched this wedding I was under the
impression that like billions of people
watch these things but I was wrong I
don't know I don't know either and then
also justice for the princess is eugenie
and be at risk because they really set
it up at this wedding yeah well they
were looking like hot messes the last
time so I'm glad that they reeled it in
a little me today they're like they're
depicted in like every move every movie
about Royals you name me like the two
crazy cousins yeah it's like it's always
about that it's in the world's to the
show yeah yeah or like even in what a
girl wants like there's always like it's
not too crazy like sisters there's very
well-represented yeah and they're I
think the characters are always based
off of the HSN you gene yeah that's yeah
that's so funny okay so now we're gonna
talk about some of the nuances of the
royal wedding and the reception details
Megan marking a toll and Prince Harry's
first dance song revealed also I'm
officially calling her Megan Windsor
because we do okay here's a remark for
the for the first song let me just
mm-hmm
this is their first song
I wanna dance with somebody hey I wanna
be there with somebody yeah I wanna
dance with somebody with somebody who
loves dance I love that first first song
like it's such a good song it's so sweet
I love it it's definitely up and it's
like age-appropriate like that's like
when they were both like coming up yeah
I think it's great and also apparently
Elton John performed your song which is
the most beautiful song of all time but
what were the numbers about the Spice
Girls don't worry what is I don't know
it was such a rumor about the Spice
Girls and like nothing Elton John isn't
prestigious because he is but like it
was so much hyper and who's performing
who's everybody like Elton John before
me out of royal wedding he doesn't at
all of them like it's just like his job
like it's like written in his contract
to be British but like they were expire
girls like that's when he got it when he
got knighted as a sir like you must
perform everywhere Sir Elton John you
agree
remember in Princess Diaries when they
do it like in front of the bus like that
crash yes oh my god oh yes no so like oh
we're just so much height like it's a
cheer no this place goes through the
reunite yeah it was none of them tell
their cuz she was an American at the top
concert was she til yeah teller Swift
Trump's wait we need to talk about the
real the America's version of the right
answer private intelligent just the
Taylor Swift concert in general so many
celebrities that like by the way weren't
there for her when she needed some
backup but would really like took sides
you know went and I think he had like an
amazing time miles teller no I know but
lectures that can be posted we're so
cute but like I don't know I'm getting
so hyped for the concert like I don't
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna work so
she has that didn't get our tickets yet
no but they're in yeah so we have I mean
she has this like lounge the reputation
impress them
and like a few fans that I get to go
before the concert and she comes in to
meets everyone that's where she met
Spencer Pratt like I'm going to do
everything in my power to get in today
yeah every day every stray like I'm
gonna do it
I might even a Spencer Pratt oh my god
his story was so evident I didn't watch
the whole thing because I had a certain
anyone through the concert right because
they watch all the police stuff and she
probably went on it like 9:30 and he was
they brought the baby I know and they
had a nurse a breastfeeding seat
they had like their own suite that I
think Heidi kept going back and forth to
to Bri this is so nice huh and I think
Taylor like set it all up so you know
she's been watching his story no but he
when he was here he was like I'm 90%
sure like she saw that look what you
made me do video that we made because
like he's a way too and like he was with
some mutual friends and he said that she
watches your shoes aware and she loves
when people are fans of hers like her
and taja core best friends cuz like
todrick did that toast with video like
yeah she loves when people like talk
about her know and in such a positive
way
he really is her number one fan he was
getting me so excited and like the
reviews that the people have been saying
about the concert like I've never heard
people talk about a concert like that
it's really like it's a show it's it's
transformative form an event like
transported in a translucent this and
then Shawn Mendes came out its
descendants Shawn Mendes is having a
moment
that's song in my blood is the best song
and it's so John Mayer it's it's so good
like hit like the other songs like
snitches and yeah there's nothing
holding me back like 100 but like oh my
god every time I hear it I'm like what
song is this oh my god - try - it is so
good and then his song youth with kid
that they perform my sight oh my god
song is beautiful last night was
beautiful but I wasn't on that one he
was together they came out with it like
two weeks together it was so good and he
looked so hot in that sweatshirt like I
was Chuck look I'm literally life alert
he need like alert I've fallen in a
can't get out he needs like a Nick Jonas
glow up where he like he needs to he
needs to back up you know what is grimy
for doesn't bother me I feel like he's
really I don't know if it's shy but it's
like awkward I don't know it's almost
like a little like like he's like above
all of this like even at the award show
I could be sitting next to Taylor and
Camila I'm like they kept showing him
and he was just like
I don't know he wasn't like giving in do
you know what I'm saying yeah no I think
I think he's a little awkward yeah never
forget that he came from the internet
yeah
Canada came from the internet and Canada
which is just you know a combination
deadly um I'm so happy Telus of sure
okay are we done
let me wrap up the real wedding I'm
pretty sure we did someone wants us to
talk about the folding chairs
what the hell was that literally 600
people had to sit in
well actually like they're really
important people up front got to sit in
church maybe yeah but like the Libyans
in the back was sitting in folding
chairs like literally like my wedding
was nicer and like there was a barrier
in between the pews and the chairs like
of walls of flowers so did they have
monitors like how did I don't John watch
the ceremony and like how did they
choose who sat in the pews like Serena
Williams had the best seat in the house
like she was adjacent from the quad
according to our followers it's because
they're like best friends oh well that's
cool and Oprah obviously was in a Pew
yeah before where it's like Abby's able
to take another chair and did you see
that they left an empty seat next to
William to represent Princess Diana it's
actually that's not true
that's what's going around but it's like
it's fake news they the seat in front of
the Queen is always left open of course
why would anyone sit in front of the
Queen right but isn't that crazy how
that just like decide it like it's true
and it's not true but they did a lot to
remember Diana which was really this
song they sang the song I was playing at
her funeral home the ring the ring at
the evening that something blue was her
ring Michael never ring is gorgeous this
is so pretty and she's so lucky the
flowers that she was holding were picked
from The Princess Anna garden okay what
do I think she's doing right now like
having something on her bed yeah that
mean was so funny
what there's a moon story like what
Megan and Harry are up to actually the
real wedding someone replied tweet
they're like having sex
probably what have you posted the
funniest thing on Instagram that I've
ever seen on me the wedding planner no
no oh no that was that to the point when
I when I saw it I was laughing and I
started choking what was it and then
when I went to sleep that night I
thought about it and I what was it the
guy between I was like what's the most
cringe-worthy
thing that's ever happened to you on a
date and the girls oh my god just good
it's not oh my god it's so funny I've
never seen like that's the funny part
I've ever laughed at I mean I know and I
was showing it to everyone like gnome
was laughing as hard as me I don't know
why it really spoke to me because if
someone ever did that yes I would divert
to me that was like when Bow Wow like
posted the picture of the plane with
Emma sitting in coach right okay I can't
let's talk about the Billboard Music
Awards because they were actually good
which is so rare because it just it was
the best word - I came I told you name a
decent memory we have a lot to people to
think Kelly Clarkson Clarkson the way
she opened the show was so raw and
beautiful and I just loved her and she
looks so good I'm like she definitely
got like lap-band or something because I
think she's losing weight way too fast
but she's trying and she never really
cared to lose weight to be good
I just think it's like a health thing I
agree and she looks amazing and she she
clearly like feels like herself I feel
like for so long in the industry she
like struggled with like wanting to be
herself and wanting to be what other
people like why do we build up all these
idols just to watch them all and the
relationship between her and Maren
Morris is so adorable I both made it
they both made it they both write songs
for each other
Marion Mehrer sings second win which is
Kelly Clarkson song they there's
something between them that I am loving
and Kelly Clarkson is so funny and I'm
sure really being herself without like
being afraid because you know what
people wouldn't like an actual celebrity
host those things like the people in the
audience always hate them they think
that they're like a little of it like
when Vanessa Hudgens did it but like I
don't know I think she like really was
like not self-conscious at all she just
like did what she wanted and I think
everyone really really responded to it
it's bittersweet for me though because
I've been dying for Kelly Carson for so
long and justice has officially been
served for her and I'm worried that like
you know now she's gonna become like
really mass famous and her tickets are
gonna be more expensive and you know
she's gonna forget the people like me
who watched her at Radio City but it's
fine it's fine okay
Taylor Swift making a surprise
appearance like honestly back when she's
to go to every award show and like sit
in the front row and dance and sing like
everyone would make fun of her like I
didn't like I was like on the bandwagon
too but like now it was like an older
person I'm like what would I do if I
went to that award show I would do
exactly what
and she's the only person having a good
time so I'm not here to make fun of her
anywhere now I won't sit next to now
everyone sings and dances and in like
the camera people are trying to get to
the peak the celebrities you know the
words the song it's like that's the like
subplot of the award shows and I was
singing last night I wonder if that was
really a thing before Taylor Swift
started singing out of work she was like
dude people dancing people sing along to
people stand up no she's a pioneer she's
a pioneer and also it's crazy cuz she
hasn't been on the red carpet in two
years but also because she hasn't put
out music so make sense but now that
like her if she wants to win the awards
for the music that she made ago so it's
interesting like she's gonna go to the
Grammys like assuming she gets nominated
and last night was like a Kardashian
free zone but it's usually not oh that's
so Jersey and presenters so it was
really her Shelley Weldon looked amazing
she did I only saw her on the red carpet
she didn't present did she yes she did
and she changed into like a kilo yellow
dress but I'm talking about the gold
dress on the red carpet she always looks
amazing her instruments did not walk the
carpet together because because they're
really dating yeah and it's not and it's
like I don't mind a couple no I'm here
for them being a fake couple because the
aesthetics are everything but be
consistent carry out fellas they're
totally great I need some follow-through
okay let's talk about some of the
performances everything one thing was
just so good I enjoyed it so much of it
Kelly Clarkson's open medley oh my I'm a
using everyone like their faces like
shining for her like everyone was like
so impressed by her and then her
performance was beyond epic she is such
a good voice and she was like at a
certain grade she knew she was killing
and she just like went off with her like
hear it with her runs and like people
literally were shook let's talk about
the one dark moment over the whole pts
no Christina and Demi you think so oh my
god first of all that song is horrible
second of all their outfits third of all
the singing and that like acting and
like literally they were just trying to
out riff each other it was so bad
here's the problem their voices are each
too much their songs that they sing on
their own albums are almost like judge
no but it's like they're they're out
singing each other they're out singing
the song the song is not like dynamic
enough for them to both be singing on it
and when they're singing together it's a
scream
yeah it's a riff-off yeah yeah yeah like
it reminds me of what Kayla settled us
and some of the greatest showmen sighs I
think if you listen to the soundtrack
over and over in kind of is your who's
screaming
she was only when they need it it was
just it was a scream some audience
members that were being particularly
thirsty
Tyra Banks Tyra Banks Jenna Dewan she
Evans well I love him more than anything
but n be calm is being out of control
how did he get that see because you
won't know why I was I because how did
Chris Emax sit in the first row in the
middle
it's an NBC produced show so and Bravo
and Andy worked for NBC Kristy Mets like
I was singing in like how about Jenna
Dewan is world of dance like it was they
were pushing their own talent and that's
right and by the way was it the most
sponsored award show ever the t-mobile
23andme like it was Kuber but I have to
be honest usually that stuff bothers me
but it didn't bother me and Macklemore
and Kesha going on tour together with
t-mobile selling $30 ticket so you have
t-mobile not that I'm with sponsored by
t-mobile but actually makes a lot of
sense but it's a really good idea and
Zack and I were arguing about it because
he was like they're that mean they
shouldn't go on that tour like they're
not good enough and I was like well a
really garden artist would never sell
out like that and an up-and-coming
artist like doesn't meet just like they
run this the Macklemore when they sing
that song good all these like everything
I know works was usually bothers me but
everything was just making me smile John
Legend's performance made me smile just
that's so that song is amazing and by
the end of the tour tender song everyone
knew the words because it's only for
line and that's because Matt why but K
the kids whose kids are those they were
incredible I'm like actually like
individually
love John Legend but like John and
Chrissy I don't love but like John
Legend
but sometimes John like didn't like
doesn't do it for me just because he
can't love everyone but last night I
loved his performance know that song
everyone was having fun and it's so nice
to have a song where everyone learned
the words by the end ya know and he
looks really cute I just I really
enjoyed his what amazing kids oh here's
was an awkward not awkward but like
interesting guest Mila Kunis and she
[ __ ] up was she and she when she was
it like before I give you somewhere
Taylor freaked out oh my god she thought
I was in like a cot like
I'm a joke moment Taylor freaked out I
freaked out and then it was a video they
the the production was a little sloppy a
couple times when they did Janet
Jackson's video and then Bruno Mars
repeated the exact same things that were
already said in the video like that
wasn't really ironed out but you know
and I get because what they did
incredible like literally breathtakingly
gorgeous weight from everyone - was it
on the red carpet or on the stage but
both should she wear the same outfit
throughout so someone who performed no
oh okay I don't know Sierra oh my god
yeah oh my god she looked incredible and
in the car with all those songwriters
we're like she was like what the hell am
i doing
she still looked gorgeous she's super
Native everyone we were in middle school
and there was a rumor that she was a man
what that was that she's literally
gorgeous that was it's like like those
see that alpha Bolivian is dead like yes
one of those conspiracy babies things
like so she looked so insanely gorgeous
also the uber thing I agree was not good
and then it was like they would all be
talking and someone would say like
something moderately profound but not
even this and maybe oh my god we need to
get that on a shirt wait I want to talk
about one word normally oh my god well
first of all okay you know I have a
problem no there she lip-sync the whole
time but in every moment in because no
Janet Jackson really did and but like
normanni doing flips like I understand
why she Jackson has a point in her
career where she's allowed to lip-sync
and phone it in because like she's made
it Marana you are coming oh well did you
think your song Camila Cabello oh I
didn't think so
oh I did um and something is just like
off with her I told her and I was saying
it's attacked during her performance
because when we watched I Heart Radio
Music sort of increment she performed
with Anna in that like pink Marilyn
Monroe thing oh my god they wouldn't
even cool go close-up on her face
because she something was just not right
and so now that's how I think of her so
I was trying to tell exactly something's
not right here
he was like no she's doing great like
she's fine and then she gave her speech
he was like okay you're right yeah no
she's weird but wait normally when did
more money become people are like saying
that normally I cannot say like what I
missed that part I missed that whole
what song does she have and that song
sticks I missed the part where she goes
solo she open
with her dancing she's a phenomenal
dancer I'm so happy for her because she
proved that like she wasn't just a cog
and the fifth harmony machine like she
is hurt but you know what she's gone
dancer when her pretending to like be
sexy be like beat again I hate what like
they like what they like came round and
Lauren Elena did that together they're
like pretending to be like about to hook
up to sell them who actually did it
we're Meghan Trainor and Charlie puth
like they actually yeah but good thank
you that's what we're ready for it yeah
totally if you're not gonna like go if
you're gonna follow through okay late
father in the chime minute so waste my
time we Jackie I need to talk just
quickly back about um normally because
you said she wasn't just a cog in the
fifth harmony machine yeah that's
exactly what she was like of the five
girls I would say she was the fourth
maybe fifth most challenge okay who do
you think is no but now that we now that
we're breaking it down I think we can
easily rule out that the one who like
just wants to like smoke pot Boran is
the second most talented it is such an
incredible singer but she's a freak and
like okay it goes like this number one
this Camilla look it always has it
always has been and I'm a fan from the
pit harmony date so I really saw them
like evolve huh Lord Reggie is an
incredible singer okay but I'm saying
like date Camilla was the best because
she's an incredible singer and an
incredible dancer
Lauren is an incredible singer she
wasn't an incredible and we don't know
that we don't know mommy was no but we
do because did was Duke it you can't
include that you can't come back I think
it's talent Lauren rhaggy Dinah Jane
maybe normanni they're tied and Ali
Hernandez is at bottom she sings but
like I don't know people are just now
like assuming she's dislike
phenomenon when like she doesn't even
have any songs no I know and the way
people tweet about her they like
stammering but like she hasn't done
anything yet no I agree I was very
confused and I was even more confused by
BTS which was okay well I also wanted to
say something else that's bothered me
and why I like normani so much is that
like nobody's really dances anymore like
and it's AJ look at Jane yes performance
was amazing and I like that song and I
always like a certain point like she can
retire and she'll never doing songs with
dj khaled anymore
no but I was being so annoying in
Thursday oh my god he was being crazy
What did he say at the end I don't know
he was throwing money at me son Ramsay
yeah oh my god
no one dances anymore like Janet Jackson
wasn't even thinking she doesn't have to
but like to Aleppo doesn't dance she
just walks at the same pace so I was
just about to bring up to Aleppo like I
thought she stunk um I thought she was
okay if she looked really good but she
doesn't dance I need I want a trip I
want a singer dancer like JLo JLo but
this is think it's impossible moonlight
dances unless you're like unless you're
JLo and you're like literally trained in
the art of singing and dancing it's
really hard to say any dance at the same
time and still be vocally sound that's
why people do that's why more money had
a track on because she was dancing like
an animal I'm like well then the Camila
kebaya was also dancing like an animal
and but she's on tour now like she's in
shape for that I guess I don't know I
just I want more dancing I love when
people dance like I think it's what
separates like the boys from them Oh
Beyonce dances and things but she has
the diaphragm to support that like she
can sing yeah roughly like she does the
breath look not everyone can do that
Beyonce's been on tour for like ten
years now where she's doing this back in
the day like when Britney used to dance
and sing like for real like there's
nothing better than that and like that's
what makes someone a superstar like I
don't need to see see an average singer
singing who can't even dance but like
Adele stands in one place on the stage
because she has the most incredible
voice like that's what you know that's
not why you're coming i but I need to
see like a duo Lippa actually I totally
ready right yeah because if you're just
gonna have like an average voice like
what separates you from everyone else
who on the void American Idol it's
almost like the industry could really
use a person who could sing and dance
like professionally so maybe I should
call some of my contacts
maybe I just I don't know why I love
just dancers yeah and that's why I
really like Jenna Dewan yeah but she is
like incredibly annoying I just started
following her so I'm just
she doesn't annoy me I don't follow her
I follow Brad Goreski and that's more
than enough for me how true he does a
really good job styling her she always
looks phenomenal she looks phenomenal
but she never really takes risks so she
always just looks good because she's not
no one needs a risk from her yet totally
I yeah I just Erika Jayne yes wait so
she hosted a red carpet for the the
billboard run like and like Andy like we
see angels return it was really awkward
but they actually showed her on TV like
twice which was really cool for her and
I love her I did not like her dress and
with those blue shoes I just it wasn't
for me
I I was just like shook over the factoid
she was there like no it was beyond
impressive also Bruno Mars sings and
dances and that's why he's the former of
our generation yes exactly why didn't he
perform I don't know he didn't win
anything he didn't perform anything
I guess because his album was like the
Lanza tours like over he's over it but
like he could have done given us some
finesse like throw us a bone here Jolla
except Kelly see straight Sutton that
was so funny I am in love with her when
she changed words to Kelly C I was like
dying no I was like where's she gonna go
with this like every and every time it
was like she has four kids I know she
said I had four kids in a kendama it was
like what did she look - I said [ __ ] you
- but maybe she twins she's like been
her head like you haven't heard from her
she's really just been having kids that
song she's saying is so good I'm a whole
lotta woman the way I walk and talk my
hair I don't think it was a great song
for her to sing in front of those people
and in front of like the pop world cuz
like it's so like it's Bruno Mars II
vibes like with the saxophone yeah it's
real music yeah and she her voice is
showcased and like now I feel like
people are gonna love that song Oh Kelly
has two stepkids so yes she does have
two of her own kids and then she's got
kids that make sense you know she wrote
like a children's book for her daughter
you know she wrote like a One Direction
song she wrote songs for everyone no I
know and it's like remember when she
said that no one would work with her on
her last album
everyone's gonna work with her now oh
wait and she's the only person here
except Anya and drama to town like and
then when she introduced John Legend or
like she came up to him after his
performance like it was all too much for
me what about the moment where Cowell
wait I'm gonna say something
controversial well what does he do when
he introduced Camilla it was so weird he
was like yeah he's British like we
obviously something mildly controversial
you know what I think I'm ready for it I
think Simon Cowell thought I that's not
controversial no like I would like I
would like let him be my sugar daddy and
I would be happy with him I think
there's nothing I have to work out some
of the details with Ben but I think John
I think he'd be done too and like he
could really like your purveyor of
talent yeah oh my god oh my god it was
an actually they gotta blinds about him
and what they say is like yeah he's like
a womanizer and he like her sex and all
these late he's like he takes care of
him like afterwards like financially and
like he just like he looks after the
women that he like has sex that that's
like to be one of those ladies also
Ariana Grande
she always at the beginning it's like
she has somewhere to be no that's
exactly what it is she like jets out she
like I don't see another picture of her
no but Frankie she's like pulled the
weight for the family I'm sorry Frank
he's really annoying I'm like I like
noise he got a friend mercy he took her
seat with his little shorts he was
really annoying me like and like he kept
getting in the shots because like when
people would walk down like he he really
pisses me off and I feel like he needs
to think you can't be on Big Brother and
also sit front row at the people Lane
like you're either gonna be a reality TV
star and like you know thirst that way
or you're gonna be the supportive
brother and you sit program well I think
like Arianna really takes care of him I
think she they both perform at the BBM a
she's like okay get my brother a front
seat like I think that's literally how I
got it she looked amazing and she Emmy
chilli sounds amazing and she's like
into that dress she wore is the same
dress she wore on it's actually a romper
it's so Kiana
yes she's our Fallon I know you get them
computation Siriano yes cute and I need
it I want to wear that in white for my
reception okay because yes stop around
BTS BTS where do they come from
I've been asleep so are they radio like
we're and everyone is in love with them
and by the way the songs are half
English half Korean I don't know the
song was good and they danced so you
know I like that ya know they were good
dancers they were I really like it every
time they were on the screen they
enlisted more of an applause than Sean
and then chlid then Justin Bieber
whatever if he was there of course what
it was crazy
did those people like to fly in and get
tickets oh there just like fans I mean
both I don't know it's just it's it was
so crazy
that's I can't believe I missed that ya
know kpop like was really popular
forever just not here right and they're
like the first people it's like trans
trans said that was what we were looking
for before
transcend transcend yeah like to
transcend outline well know when we were
talking about whose performance that was
transported they took me somewhere we
were the world of Taylor Swift's concert
is transported to okay like I feel like
I'm transported yes somewhere I'm really
excited for that concert that look last
night named evil I said and she says
marks for both Awards that she won she
mentioned the tour like yeah she goes on
she'd probably sold like a 10 to 100
that's another 15 to 100 thousand
tickets last night and I think in but
like all the celebrities
at her show on Saturday night so she
invited sleep we were already getting
tickets but I wasn't like so excited
like if I wasn't already getting tickets
I would be getting tickets after
sometime it's like finally looked good
and sounded good with Taylor like I was
really happy for I think like Taylor
keeps her in check yeah Miss Taylor like
definitely did like just not you drugs
does not party like she's focused on
like being famous forever and making a
lot of money and I think it's good for
Selena to be in like that kind of a work
environment you know what I was thinking
about though oh and I saw Taylor speech
for a second her first one was like
thank you fans like said nothing her
second one where she was like I started
writing to feel understood and when I
wrote this out of my psyche exactly yeah
you know what I'm saying I'm so caught
in the middle all his stuff hadn't
happened like the misunderstood what
would have been what would it couldn't
have been another palette without noting
about love right you know yeah what she
needed to evolve
she said medium brought her there and I
do you think that there was an album in
between 1989 and reputation that she
didn't release because she was staying I
don't think there was an album there
might be a few songs but I feel like all
like real songwriters have like tens of
20 songs like she's chillin yeah there
was supposed to be like in October where
she was due for her next album and she
waited a whole year yeah I feel like
there might be an album in there that
like I just like I'm living for the
resurgence of her in like her just doing
Instagram stories it's like I never
realized how much she didn't do until
she does it yeah I mean her Instagram is
still a little too like filtered a
little too fake like someone else is
running up yeah and it's like oh it's
just how many images and how many people
do we need to see taken that rocket
thing to the other side of the stage
it's so annoying
and she is this like mushy she has like
four different stages in the show so
like everyone really gets a great seat
and there's this little underground
tunnel that takes start from one stage
to another so she doesn't walk through
the crowd but it's like this little bed
you lay on and it shoots you and it's
ramp story every day is like another one
for guests so don't worry
trying out the oh my god that would give
me such anxiety and there's all these
little trapdoors and it shoot her up
it's good I can't oh my god she's so
brave I know but then like I feel pretty
just was like okay oh I thought she
looked beautiful and she never takes her
risk and know exactly shows looks fun
she looked like just so sweet
and she looked really happy yeah which I
remember she was at one award show like
one of her last actually that was a
really long time ago right after she
broke up with Harry and she was earning
a brown chest and she looked like so
Brown just right I know exactly what
about the brown voice is horrible
no it wasn't the dress it was like she
just looked like night and day she looks
just so happy right now she like for a
while she was like wait she's skating
like when we saw her 99 she was way too
skinny and now she just looks like
normal and happy and good and I love her
I'm really happy for her I master what a
weekend it was just filled to the brim
I'm glad we caught up and now we just
look like a oh so then John Cena and
Nikki Bella
they were seen together but like she
said they were spending every night
together so what someone got a picture
this changes nothing
but I weren't acting like it's
everything it's like not see I didn't
read the headlines we are it's Memorial
Day weekend so we're doing a show Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and then we'll be
doing podcasts for Thursday Friday no
Monday no today today Wednesday Thursday
and Friday's episodes will be just
podcasts in front Monday's Memorial Day
we will be taking it off and we'll
probably be change agents you know to
account for travel and you know not you
know I'm fighting a cold we could do a
podcast oh if there's news we'll say
it's if there's something to podcast
about we will podcast if you guys aren't
patreon members yet we released a really
great episode last week we be kept
forever Dale we interviewed snitch we've
been doing really kind of in-depth
interviewed I cried like okay so Petrie
on the morning toast is lettuce [ __ ]
it's crazy how a lot of our picture and
episodes like they there's a common
theme with like confident about
confidence like body image and like just
the way that you perceive yourself I
feel like in every episode we would come
back to that me realize I guess that's
like the most prevalent thing and the
sisters lives it's just like how weight
affects our lives but not only weight
just like how you kind of battle like
people like talking about your physical
appearance all the time and like how
that can like manipulate your confidence
and how it does my total confidence and
also what you think it's just it's so
it's so interesting so make sure you're
following the morning shows on Facebook
like us make sure you're following us
for them start again okay mix morning
taste to the morning toast goes lives
month hold on I'm Claire wait wait
take three the morning toast goes lives
come on take four the morning toast goes
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so make sure to
subscribe on Facebook make sure you like
us and then we're available on the
podcast app so make sure you subscribe
there and leave a review about how
beautiful and stunning now we are back
tomorrow and Wednesday and then we are
off with the rest of the week so make
sure you're tuning in make sure you
telling your friends make sure Sally the
watercooler knows what's going on then
keep your New Jersey in Massachusetts
for making us the most popular podcast
in your state we will see you tomorrow